eier und fisch werden erst in
künstlicher form hoch lukrativ
sebastian lege weiß mit welcher technik
die industrie lebensmittel in neuer form
auf den teller bringt
[Musik]
total lustig ne eigelb vom eiweiß immer
im gleichen verhältnis ohne rand stücke
hier haben wir das klassische stangen
produktentwickler sebastian lege weiß
selbstverständlich wie man sowas
herstellt wie wird man die lästigen
endstücke los ohne dabei material zu
verschwenden erstmal reihenweise eier
aufschlagen und das eigelb schön sauber
vom eiweiß trennen
der aufwand lohnt natürlich nicht für
ein einzelnes eier brötchen
danke das macht man sich ja sonst auch
in die haare und nicht auf die fildern
es gibt schöne glänzende locken jetzt
nur noch ein gelb und eiklar neu
zusammensetzen
aber wie
[Musik]
ich würde mal sagen handelsüblicher
laborbedarf da wir hier weiß rein füllen
was extrem klebt braucht man trennmittel
obendrauf
dafür nimmt sebastian einfaches prüfe
dann kommt noch eine zweite kleinere
röhre in die erste
[Musik]
das ganze steht in einem wasserbad jetzt
wird vorsichtig das eiweiß eingefüllt
[Musik]
erst stocken wie das eiweiß und wenn das
gestoppt ist ziehen wir die röhre raus
und befüllen es dann mit dem dotter
damit das eiweiß gleichmäßig erstarrt
erhitzt es sebastian nur ganz langsam
eigelb abstandshalter herausziehen und
das eigelb einlaufen lassen
[Musik]
bis auch das eigelb richtig fest
geworden ist vergehen einige minuten
[Musik]
naja so sie gar nicht so schlecht aus
und jetzt vorsichtig vorsichtig
rausbringen
immerhin das prinzip scheint zu
funktionieren
hey super sie so richtig klasse aus
schön fest naja außer diese komischen
zebrastreifen bin ich bis jetzt ganz
zufrieden
jetzt ab auf den stangen 1 schneider 1
23 na ja ich würde mal sagen in der
verteilung nicht ganz so gut wie das
original aber außen herum das eiklar in
der mitte das eidotter es hat
funktioniert
in der industrie werden die stangen eier
in kunst darm verpackt und tiefgefroren
so sind sie ein ganzes jahr haltbar
zusatzstoffe verhindern dass das
aufgetaute später c und gummiartig
schmeckt und das alles um ein
naturprodukt auf maximale effizienz zu
trimmen
gesundheitlich unbedenklich aber auch
nicht mehr
auf zum nächsten track einmal fisch am
block und
[Musik]
ahnen sie schon was gleich heraus kommt
sebastian leger hat fischfilets in eine
kuchenform gepresst und eingefroren
jetzt kann er sie in beliebige formen
schneiden und dann weiter verarbeiten
eine form mögen kinder am meisten
[Musik]
fertig unsere selbstgemachten für
stäbchen bisschen gesägt ratzfatz
trainiert dann kleines wellnessbad im
öl- und je sind sie schon verzehr bereit
offen keller
[Musik]
findet sogar besser
das fischstäbchen so nicht aus dem meer
kommen erkennt jeder
[Musik]
die einheitliche quader form ist
allerdings kein marketing gag sondern
praktisch für die industrielle
verarbeitung für den transport und die
verpackung umgeformt werden etwa auch
chicken nuggets oder schinken immer mit
dem ziel kosten zu minimieren und den
profit zu maximieren
denn der konkurrenzkampf der
lebensmittel hersteller ist knallhart
was denkt ihr ist es ein cleverer trick
der industrie lebensmittel in eine neue
und natürliche form zu bringen sagt es
uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips